hey YouTube have you ever wondered why
we only upload one video each month well
the answer is really easy time and money
it's fun of course but to make animation
videos like this a ridiculous amount of
time is necessary writing the script
storyboard designing all the staff
recording the narration animation sound
design and composing original music we
would love to make more videos but it's
just impossible right now without time
machine we all have real jobs and do
cuts cause out late nights and on the
weekends because it's our passion but we
prefer doing it while the sun is shining
and make more videos for you guys but
now you can help us make more science
and educational content there's this
great new thing called patreon patreon
is a crowdfunding platform like
Kickstarter but it works on a monthly
basis with smaller amounts if you want
you can support us with a small sum each
month and we'll spend this time working
elsewhere and make more videos depending
on the amount you'll get cool rewards
like graphics for your smartphone or
computer our music links in the video
description or I'll record your
voicemail message this is the mailbox of
a man called Jimmy Wow something like
that even the smallest amounts helpful
we really appreciate it our videos will
stay free on YouTube forever so if you
don't want to fund us nothing will
change for you if we get enough money
through patreon we can invest more time
in cuts cause us and make more than one
video every 4 weeks in the future thank
you for your attention lots of love all
the fields cuts goes out
you